Jack where's your foot man you had one
job Deb I remember last time we played
people got angry but that we weren't
good enough hope they're not expect
anything different they all the same
things are here look at my guy like you
just like fire to do something I am the
happiest ain't gay yes Hardy Santa I'm
the depression candy canes grumpy Santa
I am the I just saw some ass Santa like
oh yeah that booty says tits and that
mom I'm disclaimer I have no idea what
happens in this game me either
I have all the ideas AIRAID Santa tan
baby it's masculine hey where's our van
going on really we don't even hey guys
let's go in the roof all right guys I'm
coming through the roof ah you came down
the chimney exactly is Angela O'Hara
specific it's in a tree hey hey let's
put some dead people in the tree
yeah look at look at look at how we do I
just took this guy's hostage all right I
got a hostage down I'm down
oh my legs they keep why do they keep
shooting as I have hostage she shot the
high shot him take you shot my ass are
you [ __ ] kidding me what's wrong with
America today
cops shooting everybody you shot it
looks like you're judging the [ __ ] out
of me I can't believe you what I did it
I don't shave my balls don't hood
my beard is not as adequate as you guys
know it no no it was okay hey boy this
is weird
what are we robbing hearings ah oh no
shout at the pilot to wake him up wake
up oh I thought you said shoot at the
pally
shout shout okay I shot him in the face
he's alive
party too hard last night he's hungover
okay I look at him happy
yeah I passed a DA Oh God behind us
there's what people
it's the atheists they're here to stop
Christmas no he'll be had
down front of it pat out oh wow what
advice oh yeah he did it use if I see
you later really you can do it oh my god
how did you do that how do you tell it
teaches we're so damn oh you [ __ ]
ah Christmas present I what I'm just
gone baby dick oh shoot it yeah it's
beautiful it's beautiful spank that disc
magic it's a destination
I got you jack thank you you thinking
yeah I need to sing Santa Claus songs
ding about jiggle too late it's too
[ __ ] late okay clover being Santa
Claus songs jingle bells jingle bells
jingle all the way I'm a jack
sing a jack they're your buzz there you
go that's all I ever asked we gotta get
the pilot there he's gonna floss look
come on you piece of [ __ ] he's the only
one that could do it go down the stairs
cut in custody yesterday you gotta come
no they got ya
I have a prison flare again hey gift hey
what do we got Oh cocaine nice okay the
greatest gift of the Mod I'm being
molested right now breath you drop this
opening damn it can I drop the soap and
it was liquid soap so I can't actually
pick it up that's the worst so I used it
for Lube instead why's everyone down
clubbers in custody two wires now why do
you go down a piece of [ __ ] ah fire at
least I've delivered the cocaine okay
this time I say no to voice crack I'm
really sad magic if Kris guys can you
stop having fun we're trying to do this
oh look at a gallop you know how I got
you up I just peed in your face la Santa
P that's if strong Sushil Modi is very
job it's roomy
it's filled with cocaine left over it
just it just snapped me right away can I
go on
oh [ __ ] oh yeah yeah all right well I
miss big okay yeah so what so what do we
do now if you [ __ ] left us Oh
activate another oh my god yeah what do
you see he's getting shot in the face oh
my god Jackson city well well I don't
think we can do it guys we really suck
at Christmas don't mind the bulletproof
vests yeah you guys is that what's going
on here where's my job they're being
suspicious there's a blinking water
detectives the sound driving so quiet
gone oh wait he buried a cup sponge a
gig I can well that's just too bad
Oh where's Ken let's save Ken Oh [ __ ]
okay why do you look so sad yeah yeah
hey look at that
I [ __ ] epic saved you hey what are
you looking at being so dead for hey do
you have the key card hey buddy nice
shirt used to drill huh how do I use it
uh I don't f we wish you a Merry
Christmas we wish come on oh you guys
need me to pee in your faces
hello no we wish you Merry Christmas
they knew you good tidings we bring for
you
and
we all have one minute left I don't know
so many we wish you a very rich man
you only got 21 seconds try to really
114 ah are we just saying numbers 21 25
26 eight hundred six to one it's in it's
in as you she said what do you have I'm
inside you oh okay this thing it I don't
I don't brother
Oh guys look they're all here guys look
oh naira tax money stop it we're on the
roof they're everywhere
oh god I think I went down yeah I'm down
this is John I love Santa Claus I wish
you a Merry Christmas I wish a Merry
Christmas
we're so a matrix created we suck at
this game okay well it was fun serving
by your side now can all circle by each
other in jail Oh Oh double jail
I can't wait to do some shopping with
your bread oh it's a ripoff of goat
simulator let's play it
I can either be demon from Hell or or
demon from hell I'll go with pork even
thank you ha